tja also erstmal freue ich mich aus dem
71 prozent der weltweiten ackerfläche
viele zahlen hat einen moralischen
aus einem langen urlaub wieder da zu
diebstahl das muss natürlich brauchen
sterben weil wir gerne jeden tag fleisch
überschwang mit beiden kann ich nicht
verwendet der menschheit tierfutter 71
wir ihn fragen lebensschutz gesetzt
sein ich komme allerdings mit schlechtem
essen das ist eben mein problem ich wo
dienen ich habe nur den eindruck
supermärkte verpflichtet werden ab einer
ich kannte das thema auch ich habe mich
gewissen zurück denn als ich zurückkam
und nur 18 prozent für lebensmittel
wenn jetzt hier in deutschland also mehr
auch jetzt erst damit beschäftigt die
habe ich meine speisekammer und mein
gewissen quadratmeter größe die
zahlen sind erschreckend sei eigentlich
veganisch restaurant aufmachen dann was
lebensmittel die sie wegschmeißen zu
das ist ja absolut grotesk wenn wir
kühlschrank ausgemistet und habe dabei
ein kleiner fun fact die
ändert es dann am konsumverhalten das
rindfleischproduktion ist der größte
weniger fleisch essen machen wir damit
spenden im moment ist die rechtslage so
so viele lebensmittel weggeschmissen
eben angesprochen war von den chinesen
flächen fresser das heißt dass wir
die fläche frei oft werden getreide oder
dass er das ich zum nachdenken gekommen
und haben das habe ich versucht das
es gibt ihn letzte woche endlich gibt es
deutschland wäre vermessen so viel
kartoffeln angebaut werden können
erstmal nicht viel rauchen die
im moment in koblenz ein fall wo zwei
wenn danach dann ein bisschen nach
rindfleisch und zum beispiel dass wir
anbauflächen wir brauchen die anderen
recherchiert habe und ich habe ich bin
letztlich ist dieser krieg so süchtig
die anbauflächen für die ränder
studenten angeklagt sind wegen des
das heißt wenn wir wenn wir 50
fürchterlicher ist muss eine chance als
sogenannten containern sind so einem
zu einem erschreckenden ergebnis
quadratmeter für rindfleisch brauchen
natürlich dann im ausland haben also
gekommen
supermarkt gegangen habe frische
können ja dieser zeit an diesen auf
während nämlich in unseren breiten mehr
sind wir wir könnten deutschland ist gar
lebensmittel geklaut und ist das
chance gesehen werden eine
diesen 50 grad eben nicht nachhaltigen
nicht groß genug um einen dazu füttern
grundsatzdebatte über unseren umgang mit
bedürftigen zu geben und es ist stehen
als ein drittel aller lebensmittel in
aber klar macht getreide der nicht an
die wir die die wir essen
essen anzuregen wir müssen neu lernen
wegen diebstahls vor gericht absolut
bleu müll landen stehen die länder der
dem chinesischen fleischhunger oder dem
keiner wir brauchen mehr sendungen wie
mit unserer nahrung umzugehen wir müssen
für ein kilo rindfleisch werden
indischen sender nichts dran und 2001
deine leidenschaft zu reden gerade
dritten welt vor einer absolut
entdeckt hast du das noch mal machen
sowie quadratmeter einfach genau und
unseren fleisch bedarf reduzieren sowie
außerhalb der eu wo die wurde ja
katastrophalen ernährungs und hungers
dass hier mit alexander von schönburg
einsatz wo ich glaube ich generell nicht
dass unsere eltern und großeltern
meistens herkommen von der außerhalb die
kommt noch mal hierhin und wird dann
davon abgesehen von diesem problem was
praktiziert haben und wir müssen unsere
krise die sachlage ist die folgende
uhr bis zu 49 quadratmeter fläche
ich erkenne aber dieser drastik jetzt
über lebensmittel sprechen
diese ernährungskrise wird vom krieg in
für das individuelle verhalten auch
böden für unsere ernährung und nicht für
benötigt für ein kilo rindfleisch fast
nicht ganz sehr ich glaube nicht dass
die ernährung der tiere
50 quadratmeter fläche aber um ein kilo
realität und politik immer nach dem
rust von russlands gegen die ukraine
nutzen
prinzip der kommunizierenden röhren
enorm verschärft fast 30 prozent der
funktioniert also wenn wir hier weniger
die lösung muss her kaufen tatsächlich
kartoffeln anzubauen worden ein viertel
haben da gibt es woanders gut auch wenn
weltweiten weizenexporte stammt aus der
nur das was wir essen statt den dritteln
quadratmetern ein viertel quadratmeter
wir uns hier entlasten kommt es sofort
ukraine und russland die folgen der
bei woandershin verschiebungen auf
für ein kilo kartoffeln fast 50
unsere lebensmittel wegzuschmeißen und
jährigen deutschen ich glaube nicht dass
entlasten dadurch die
dritten welt sind dramatisch extreme
quadratmeter für ein rindfleisch das
man eins zu eins dieser effekt erreichen
nahrungsmittelproduktion
preissteigerungen von getreide und
heißt wenn sie die wenn sie weltweit wir
wird ich glaube das war ein aspekt
also die zahlen die sie ja nennen dass
saatgut die folgen sind unvermeidbar
müssen das ja wenn du wirst uns ja nicht
überhaupt noch nicht betrachtet haben
wir ein drittel unserer lebensmittel
nur aus deutscher perspektive
und das ist ja die frage also ich glaube
nahrungsknappheit und also auch
wegwerfen also die erschrecken natürlich
betrachten sondern wir müssen sehen dass
nicht dass man so viele menschen auch
hungersnöte und das groteske ist und
erschreckend mich auch ich mir war das
die die mit landwirtschaftlichen flächen
sagen ich würde gerne aus im interesse
gar nicht so bewusst aber dich selber in
damit komme ich jetzt wieder auf meinen
global
der nahrungsmittel gerechtigkeit oder
meinem eigenen
überfüllten kühlschrank zurück und den
beschränkt sind das die
erleben und in meinem eigenen handelns
auch des weltfriedens auf fleisch
nahrungsmittelbedarf immer höher wird
von mir weggeschmissen in lebensmitteln
auch nicht so habe werde ich in urlaub
verzichten das ist in den umfragen so
fahre dass das weiß ich ja vorher das
und der bedarf nach pflanzlichem eiweiß
während die dritte welt mit
wir kennen das aus den bio umfragen
ist meistens ja nicht kurzfristig dann
nahrungsmittelknappheit zu kämpfen hat
immerhin wird denn die den ländern wie
schaue ich dass ich wenn ich wegfahre
viele leute würden nur noch bio kaufen
indien und china ist es natürlich so
gehen wir verantwortungslos
mein kühlschrank leer ist oder dass da
dass eben die mittelklasse radikal
aber es tun eben nur wenige ja das ist
verschwenderisch mit unserem essen um
vielleicht noch eine haltbare sachen
drin sind also das heißt weil sich
und werfen wie gesagt ein drittel
das muss man einfach so sehen die
steigt das heißt der bedarf nach
richtigerweise sagt und was kann jeder
aspekte überhaupt noch nicht betrachtet
hochwertiger luxuriöser nahrung steigt
unserer lebensmittel weg das muss mich
einzelne tun ich glaube jeder einzelne
wurde ist aber die frage können wir
muss für sich überlegen wie keiner
war sofort dass sich vorstellen man geht
das ist irgendwo muss das hierher kommen
nicht fleisch substituieren oder auch
bewusster damit umgehen weil in der tat
im supermarkt man kommt mit drei tüten
liegt die chinesen kaufen im moment hat
anders herstellen da sind ja
das belastet uns auch alle wenn wir
afrika auf aber nicht nur um dort um
nach hause und einer der drei tüten
gentechnisch schon vielleicht dinge
bilder sehen in afrika an anderen
schmeißt man gleich so ist so ist die
dort zu bauen oder was die bauen die die
locker fleisch aus dem 3d drucker
lage
stellen der welt wo die menschen hungern
was kann jeder einzelne tun und
sozusagen das sind dinge die jetzt im
kaufen halb afrika auf um dort dann die
und wir leben im überfluss dass das
die entscheidende frage und die antwort
kommen sind das sind auch dinge glaube
rinder zu füttern die die mack
macht einem jahr wie sie richtig sagen
wachsenden mittelklasse in china essen
ist wir müssen unser konsumverhalten
vielleicht wirklich auch ein schlechtes
ich auf die man eher das augenmerk
gewissen aber ich bestimmt in einem
will wenn wir da jetzt nicht daran gehen
richten muss als auf die frage des
zusammenhang es ist jetzt bestellten
verzichts wir müssen einfach schauen was
haben wir ein problem und das heißt das
ändern wir müssen wirklich überdenken
zusammenhang aber ich bin da sind wir
fleisch das sie essen geht auf kosten
können wird technisch machen dann können
überhaupt wie wir die achtung gegenüber
uns auch ganz schnell einig die frage
wir nämlich das vermeiden dass man immer
der
ist allerdings wie reagieren wir darauf
dem dem dem dem der nahrung haben
diese verzichts ideologie den leuten
ernährung der menschen im unternehmen
ich glaube das was der einzelne tun kann
verkauft als irgendwie was tolles das
das muss er auch tun da brauchen wir
sich mal eine provokante frage 1
nicht ein bewusstsein dafür allerdings
problem ist nur es ist nicht umsetzbar
alexander kissler stellen gehört ist
das wichtigste ist ein weniger
die frage und darauf in diese richtung
hierzulande mag das sein dass wir
denn nicht auch diese freiheit
dadurch ein bisschen was an aber die
lebensmittel wegschmeißen zu dürfen
verschwenderischen umgang mit
geht es ja sozusagen fleischkonsum da
leute die bisher noch überhaupt keinen
nahrungsmitteln zu haben und womöglich
ist man ja ganz schnell sozusagen von
wohlstand haben den zu sagen hier sollte
allgemein betrachtet also verständlich
auch wenn das viele fleischesser mich
der infragestellung des fleischkonsums
auch in zukunft nichts haben ich möchte
also eigentlich ist ein lebensmittel ist
aber noch lang so etwas tut du hast
ganz schnell auch dann bei gesetzlichen
eingeschlossen ungern hören und ich habe
mein eigentum das habe ich erworbene
vorgaben wir hatten ja mal das thema
gern fleisch aber es muss vielleicht
gesagt du hast gerade hat karsai nennt
gestohlen habe da kann ich mich
renate künast war seinerzeit die
nicht jeden tag seiner stücke in der
verfahren ich kann ihn theoretisch auch
er aber ganz ganz kurz
generation vor uns oder bei meinen
zu vergnügen gibt es ja auch mein auto
invasion gefordert hat und solche sachen
kaufen das kaputtmachen sinnlos und
großeltern das man halt am sonntag
man kauft weg schmaler in der
wo man den menschen dann sozusagen
fleisch gegessen hat wir müssen mehr
vorschreibt wie sie zu leben haben
unvernünftig aber ich darf ist man
deutschland ist die rechtslage so dass
hinwendung zur pflanzlichen
sollte natürlich sinnlos und vernünftige
wieder zu essen haben und das wäre etwas
wenn du zu einem supermarkt geben
nahrungsmitteln haben warum und wo ist
übrigens lieblingsmotiv wegschmeißt
dinge nicht ewig mal aber und
was ich jedenfalls nicht mitgehen konnte
der zusammenhang der hohe fleischkonsum
geständnisse unethisch können jetzt auch
ich glaube wir müssen ein bewusstsein
quote noch sehr viel höher weil
sein übrigens hat mich weil ich hier ein
in den industrieländern verknappt die
diplomaten wie genau genau wie du den
für die menschen hoffen dass wenn ich
wenig natürlich jetzt etwas
richtig wir dürfen keine vorschriften in
supermarkt geht und zu irgend und aus
flächen die weltweit für den
auf haben acht gehen lässt innerlich ist
der ball strich aber fortschritte auf
dem container perfekte lebensmittel raus
nahrungsmittelanbau zur verfügung stehen
der anderen seite der erde menschen
der kollege ist sehr gut vorbereitet
nimmt in deutschland ein rechtsbruch ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]